been simply wonderful in their
generosity making this magic in st.
Louis happen and half of the Sinquefield
show is dr. jeanne singh field and we
would say the better half - because rex
is crazy
I didn't she's the reason number one of
the family you need the dreamers and you
need the practical ones and welcome
first of all thanks for joining us
you're seeing this u.s. championship
happen what does it feel like to see
this come to the st. Louis year after
year I was sort of like when we started
with you you do one year and and you
didn't realize how big a deal it was you
should have asked them they say sure you
can have it your club okay come out ten
years later yeah it's like we're in
streaming it live 191 countries and
starting all these chess tournaments and
chess clubs and people are getting fired
up about chess in America it's great you
know definitely made a big impact a huge
impact I know you also have other
initiatives as well tell us about the
Boy Scouts initiative that just seems to
be mushrooming right now yeah it's like
we had this little thing where Rex was
you know the club was starting and
teaching chess in a few schools you know
so I always like to compete so Boy
Scouts of America and generously I
talked to them and they started to prove
the chest merit badge so I now have
170,000 boys who were in the chest merit
badge so this is my little back on Rex
that's extraordinary so then he came
back and did the Sinquefield Cup okay so
you know I have to sort of come back
with something back right and with the
Eagle Scouts I think we have some video
on your Eagle Scouts initiative well the
Eagle well here's what's happening I
didn't have to do this is the best part
of what I do Rex has to do all this work
and spend money and stuff I just do a
sock Tom Sawyer approach I need to look
that way I'm just showing you this
graphic we are on the screen with the
Eagle Scouts oh projects
special projects lolz grace special
operations forces and first responders
pretty pretty extraordinary looking
chessboard there go army when I see is
one of the squares yeah this is Duncan
Guthrie created this life-sized chess
board beautiful for a special forces
retreat place the sort of honor each of
the pieces is in it but what was great
about this is I didn't have to do
anything
Eagle Scout or not life Scouts who are
trying to do an eagle project look and
said we can do something in chess and so
there's just these wonderful Eagle
projects so if you're a life Scout out
there or you're a chess club call your
local Boy Scout Troop why don't make a
chess park for you or make or teach
Chester disabled kids or lots of in
because there's so it's a very important
point we should make that note about
that if you you do have that in your
area definitely check out the Boy Scouts
because there's so many of them
I mean 170 thousands more I think than
the membership in the US Chess
Federation so think about that that's a
massive number so those of you are
trying to promote chess in your neck of
the woods
check out the Boy Scouts and the
initiative that has been started by dr.
Jeanne Singh field we do know we have
chess runs in the family
in the same field family Rex of course
is the godfather of it all as you say
but he's got some young grandkids who
are starting to play chess oh we have
some beautiful video Wow
winning chess strategy that's young
Lincoln I believe yeah yeah the video I
think he was reading aloud from the
chess chess book he's just learned to
read to Mary 5 Wow you know while
they're young yeah and he was reading
about you know a chest strategy to his
mom so he can teach his mom how to play
chess oh my goodness is he ready to beat
Rex yet no but I think that Logan
myah son Randy's oldest is working on
that are we gonna see a young Singh
field in the C field cup one day I don't
know it's always possible we totally
appreciate your generosity and all the
work that you do you also anything we're
gonna do what is that I'm trying to talk
I haven't they haven't agreed or
anything national to have a national boy
scout team tournament sure like the
protest League mm-hmm have teams in each
in four regions across the country and
then they'll bring the winners to st.
Louis to find the best boy scout team in
America very nice they haven't agreed
discussion right don't you think if you
would have a grand
you're a pro chess league right well III
think you know as convincing as dr. Judy
Singh field can generally be yeah I
think we know it's going to happen thank
you so much for everything that you do
for chess and continue to do for chess
we really appreciate the generosity
thank you thank you yeah and those Eagle
Scout projects were actually described
in chess Life magazine and one of them
was about somebody who created a video
series for the disabled and then the
other one was